[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 17 octobre
bienvenue dans le journal préparé par la
rédaction de tv 60,18 voici les titres
de l'actualité locale intensifier la
prise en charge des jeunes de 3 à 25 ans
pour leur réussite scolaire dans et en
dehors de l'école 35 territoire
francilien dont quatre dans les yvelines
ont été a labellisé par l'état cité
éducative
que change cette attribution et quel
projet mise en place exemple dans cette
édition attrape la polémique enfle au
potager du roi à versailles un article
du figaro pointe la lente agonie du lieu
géré par à l'école nationale supérieure
du paysage
l'établissement a contre attaqué hier en
proposant une visite du site quelle est
la situation éléments de réponse et puis
l'open de france de golf s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui 7 au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à dimanche les
meilleurs sportifs de la discipline
seront en compétition
mais pour débuter ce journal on part à
poissy où la journée sans poids lourds
se poursuit jusqu'à ce soir organisé par
la ville cette opération était destinée
à lutter contre les nuisances générées
par les camions en transit
or ils iront aux amis qui allaient lui
donner que c'est interdit
élu policiers municipaux et bénévoles
ils sont une cinquantaine mobilisés sur
trois axes clés à poissy pour cette
quatrième journée sans poids lourds
seuls les véhicules en transit sont
concernés objectif lutter contre les
nuisances sonores les nuisances
olfactives et la pollution
typiquement ici nous sommes sur un
endroit où les poids lourds qui viennent
là viennent de saint germain et
maisons-laffitte
au lieu de continuer vers la rn 184 il
traverse la ville de poissy pour aller
chercher la trêve ce qui leur fait
gagner 25 minutes à bien leur fait faire
demi tour
lors de la dernière opération 55% des
poids lourds contrôlés étaient en
infraction contre 70% pour la première
édition camion mais
l'interview on sait pas pour lui
pas de verbalisation mais seulement de
la prévention et des distributions de
feu ailleurs ce pour cette journée la
municipalité souhaite néanmoins aller
plus loin moi je réclame l'élargissement
de la police du maire pour justement
faire en sorte que les poids lourds qui
traversent la ville de poissy soit
sévèrement verbaliser aujourd'hui à la
verbalisation à les porter à 35 euros
minorée à 22 euros
demain il faut porter ce chiffre à 500
voire 1500 euros une nouvelle opération
sans poids lourds à poissy devrait avoir
lieu au printemps 2000 20 35 territoires
concernés en ile de france le 5
septembre dernier les ministres de la
ville et de l'éducation nationale ont
annoncé lé territoire labellisé cité
éducative l'objectif lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire en intensifiant la
prise en charge des élèves pendant et
après la classe notamment par des
activités culturelles et sportives mais
pas que dans les yvelines quatre villes
sont concernées par le dispositif vous
les voyez s'afficher
chanteloup-les-vignes mantes-la-jolie
les mureaux et rap
bonsoir génie de marie première maire
adjointe de trappes en charge notamment
de l'éducation comment la ville de
trappes at elle accueilli
l'attribution de ce label favorablement
et c'est une considération du travail
qui est fait par toutes les équipes
depuis maintenant cinq ans le pdt le
projet éducatif de territoire numéro 2 a
été votée au mois de juin l'année
dernière et neuf mois après est sorti la
cité éducative qui reprend très
largement la philosophie des du pe dtc
la ville de trappes qui a fait la
démarche pour tout pour être un organe
demande et donc c'est l'état qui est
venue vers vous avec avec ce label je le
disais l'idée de ce label c'est
finalement de coordonner l'ensemble des
acteurs autour de projets pour ces
quartiers prioritaires alors pour
intensifier la prise en charge des
jeunes de 3 à 25 ans pour leur réussite
scolaire dans et en dehors de l'école ça
c'est important en dehors de l'école une
fois qu'on a dit ça gêne il marie qu'est
ce que ça change concrètement d'avoir ce
label est ce que finalement ce n'est pas
un dispositif en plus il en existe
beaucoup sur sur l'école sur la réussite
scolaire n'existe beaucoup sur l'école
et notamment sur la ville mais dans le
dans le cas présent et pour la ville de
trappes comme c'est très largement
inspiré du projet éducatif de territoire
qui a été votée l'année dernière pour
nous ça ne change pas grand chose a
élargi au lieu de prendre que
l'éducation c'est leur vie à la ville en
entier et ça permet d'avoir des actions
supplémentaires qui étaient programmés
mais à la charge 100 % du budget ville
d'être financée par l'etat sera portée
des performances des financements de
l'état dormant de l'état 85 mille euros
d'ici la fin de l'année pour des actions
qui sont déjà portés à 100% pour la
ville et d'autres qu'on avait en
portefeuille pour développer on
développait pas parce qu'à un moment
donné un air ça ne fait que deux même
s'il ya de bonnes intentions derrière on
passe pas deux et demi et donc ça va
nous permettre de faire encore plus
alors depuis l'annoncé de cette
attribution vous travaillé sur
l'élaboration d'un projet alors même si
au travers vous le disiez du projet
éducatif de territoire il y avait déjà
des choses en discussions mais ça
continue
quand je tiens le ministère a donné des
orientations qui sont déjà pour nous
dans le pdt donc ça change pas grand
chose au niveau de ce qui est à faire
le rectorat a donné ses propres
orientations et se décline comme sarah
et nous on arrive en bout de piste
donc on retombe sur l'état d'esprit de
ce qu'on avait fait au niveau du pdt
alors si je vous dis ça fait des actions
qui existent déjà qui sont labellisés et
puis d'autres qui vont se développer
notamment plus largement puisque c'est
la ville en entier ça inclut et par an
non cette semaine il y avait un
séminaire à la sorbonne de travailleurs
mais dites vous n'y avez pas assister
mais en tout cas il ya des informations
qui ont souvent cette formation qui
qu'ils sont
redescendu puisque on considère au
regard du travail qui a été fait sur le
projet éducatif de territoire celui ci
devient la politique socle de la cité
éducative sur la ville et ce qui est
c'est éducatif ce sont les actions
prioritaires définis par l'état mais ça
ne met pas entre parenthèses celles qui
sont déjà en projet plus il était
d'accord ok en plus et alors quels sont
ses projets en plus juste dans ses
actions chaudes et je vais vous les
donner parce que je ne les connais pas
par coeur
c'est la persévérance et l'ambition
parce que c'est vrai qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'au niveau des collèges surtout le
persévérance en matière de travail ça
s'égrènent au fur et à mesure c'est
l'âge le plus difficile c'est aussi
l'ouverture du champ des possibles mais
ça nous ça fait cinq ans qu'on est sur
le champ des possibles la deuxième le
deuxième axe c'est l'ouverture sur le
monde
environnement et source d'émancipation
ça on le fait déjà ce qu'il ya des
voyages jeunesse y compris à l'étranger
dans le dans le soutien ou à certaines
populations c'est la santé bien-être et
le climat scolaire soit on le fait avec
dans le vivre bien vivre ensemble avec
les ateliers philosophiques le théâtre
et puis l'association en cat qui
travaille sur les faits religieux qui
fait d'information au personnel
animations mais aussi éducation
nationale et puis le lac est le
quatrième axe et la parentalité
on est déjà dedans depuis une dizaine
d'années et on se rongeaient les défis
n'avait que deux acteurs des détours de
tous les acteurs comme on l'a toujours
fait et
et l'état rend plus l'état ont plus qui
cette fois le plus que l'éducation
nationale dans la cité éducative prend
la main sur ce que faisait les communes
le calendrier d'ici la fin de l'année
fait pas d'ici la fin de l'année c'est
en fin de semaine de croire son rang la
copie vous rendez la copie et donc les
actions seront subventionnés à partir de
la fin de l'année que ce soit pour la
fin de l'année où une partie pour la fin
de l'année après ça s'étale sur trois
ans très bien et quels sont vos
espérances du coup autour de ce nouveau
label canton à 5000 euros
quand on n'avait pas espérer qu'ils vont
nous arriver et qui permet effectivement
vous faire plus et de poursuivre ses
projets sur la ville merci jeanine mari
d'être passé en plateau première
adjointe de la ville de trappes
notamment
en charge de l'éducation c'est le rendez
vous des élus des yvelines les
universités des mairies se sont tenues
au port-marly airs mercredi toute la
journée les maires ont pu rencontrer des
partenaires publics et privés échanger
sur leurs sur leurs conditions
d'exercice retour sur cette journée avec
nicolas d'andry ils sont 259 dans les
yvelines 36 dans les hauts-de-seine les
maires des deux départements avaient
rendez vous pour la première fois
ensemble aux universités des mairies des
ateliers des tables rondes organisées
pour les élus municipaux avec notamment
des partenaires d'autres collectivités
en avantage
non
écoutez la nécessaire que nous
les maires refusent de travailler en
bonne intelligence et avec cette
reconnaissance de la tente
préfet vous avez cité il est fait nous
avons apprécié complet pour l économie
koné
si le contexte est difficile les
communes peuvent bénéficier des devenant
des intercommunalités des départements
des régions et de l'état à travers les
services déconcentrés des aides sur le
vélo des aides sur les transports
propres des aides sur le verdissement de
la ville des aides sur le patrimoine
avec un bonus de 200 mille euros pour
tous les villages qui ont des besoins de
rénovation de patrimoine
je n'oppose pas la nécessaire
décentralisation et son
approfondissement à un état qui soit
renforcée sur le territoire antagonisent
et les uns les autres n'a pas de sens
nous avons besoin les uns des autres des
partenaires privés présents du secteur
de l'immobilier des travaux publics ou
du transport avec de curieuses
découvertes comme le gouvernail un
mélange entre la boussole et la carte un
moyen d'information pour se déplacer et
valoriser le patrimoine d'une commune
une idée de la start-up vague lancée il
ya moins d'un an
je veux par exemple aller sur le stand
de la sncf je sais pas ce qu on le sent
la sncf donc j'ai juste à chercher à la
lettre s sncf sur un secteur 3ème je
prends gouvernail je tourne avec lui
positionne le secteur 3 devant moi et
voilà je vois immédiatement sncf
je me suis mis physiquement et
mentalement face à ma destination
cette solution pourrait apparaître
prochainement dans les rues yvelinoise
et à l'occasion de ces universités des
mairies représentants de l'état élus
locaux et monde agricole se sont réunis
pour signer un document la charte de bon
voisinage a pour but de mettre fin à ce
qu'on appelle communément la grille
bashing c'est à dire le dénigrement des
agriculteurs signature dans un contexte
particulier dans les yvelines trois
communes ont pris des arrêtés anti
pesticides à la charte engage les
agriculteurs vis-à-vis des habitants sur
un certain nombre de points écouter ses
interviews il est important que on ne
dresse pas les français les uns contre
les autres à partir d'informations
imiter tronquées ou excessives
il convient que chacun comprenne que les
agriculteurs sont des français comme les
autres c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
fond et on fait des efforts
considérables pour s'adapter
au changement de réglementation
européenne et française
et qu'ils ne font pas leur travail de
façon pire que d'autres que des
industriels oman que des particuliers on
s'engage à utiliser notamment au théâtre
technique qui permet la limite de
dérives de nos produits phytosanitaires
par l'utilisation par exemple de buses
anti dérive par un certain nombre de
facteurs qui sont déjà prévues par la
loi mais par exemple le fait de passer
un permis à traiter la transparence sur
notre façon de travailler
la réduction des doses ne pas traiter à
des ventes plus de 19 km heure enfin
tout un tas de facteurs aujourd'hui qui
sont très engageant pour l'agriculteur
que la population voit sans doute pas
mais qui vise à limiter justement cet
impact et le risque qui pourrait y avoir
en fait vis-à-vis des habitants
la lente agonie du potager du roi c'est
le titre de l'article de nos confrères
du figaro à propos de ce site historique
de versailles accusée de ne plus
s'occuper des arbres fruitiers de
laisser les lieux à l'abandon les
jardiniers l'école nationale supérieure
de paysages prennent la parole pour
établir la vérité quelle est la
situation sur place mathilde et demi et
ce talent et au potager du roi le
potager du roi est au coeur d'une
controverse suite à l'article du figaro
du 4 octobre 2019 qui explique photos à
l'appui
la dégradation du jardin l'école
nationale supérieure de paysage rappelle
que la construction du potager a
commencé en 1678 et que de nombreuses
restaurations ont été faites
malgré le manque de mécénat
effectivement les les photos montrent
des murs qui sont dans un état dégradé
puisque nous avons fait des diagnostics
assez approfondies et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a
une part importante des murs 15% des
murs qui nécessite une intervention
urgente 30% qui nécessitent des
interventions rapides mais effectivement
nous sommes en mesure aujourd'hui de
déployer un programme de travaux des
parcelles vides ou abîmées des murets
qui s'effrite des arbres en mauvais état
pour cela 4 5 millions d'euros vont être
utilisés pour des travaux de rénovation
l'objectif du potager et de retirer les
arbres pour reconstruire les murs et du
jardin puis replantés les espèces des
travaux qui commenceront fin 2019 et qui
s'étendront sur 2020
quand on refait un mur ça veut pas dire
que tout d'un coup il ya d un fruitier
dessus il ya du temps un temps de
conservation de préservation nos sols et
un temps de remise en vie de nos sols il
ya un temps de mise en place sur le mur
le temps que le mur lui même on va dire
arrête de bouger
donc il faut compter entre le moment où
un mur héros fait est que ce mur est
beau d'un point de vue de la production
il faut compter bien 8,9 peut-être même
dix ans des dégradations datant depuis
la fin du 19ème siècle qui s'accumulent
et qui nécessitent aujourd'hui de
nombreuses restaurations les jardiniers
du potager du roi prévoit donc le
renouvellement du patrimoine arboré dans
les années à venir au tremblay sur
mauldre le centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion a un
nouveau directeur c'est stéphane amiot
bonsoir bonsoir nouveau directeur donc
que du chef vous venez de prendre la
suite de laurent terme qui était en
poste depuis 2000 14 comment vous
aborder ses nouvelles fonctions vous qui
avait occupé auparavant à un poste de
directeur de cfa s'était spécialisé dans
les courses hippiques c'est ça chante i
où la bande les commandes du coup ce
nouveau rôle moi j'aborde
sereinement et avec enthousiasme alors
cette expérience justement que vous avez
acquises dans l'apprentissage ce que
c'était dans le domaine de
l'apprentissage dans un cfa
en quoi elle va vous servir comme en
aval bout elle va vous servir pour pour
ce nouveau rôle mon expérience que j'ai
pu acquérir autant lui faire la
différence
direction le centre de formation permet
de pouvoir reprendre le pilotage de la
demande arrivé en pilotage de
l'établissement et puis donc mes
connaissances dans la formation
professionnelle et mon appétence pour la
formation professionnelle également donc
on va me permettre de pouvoir
accompagner le chef et ses équipes dans
la stratégie de la stratégie de
développement de l'établissement
et quelle est la stratégie justement
quelles sont vos ambitions à mes
ambitions c'est au bas de faire du shape
un acteur incontournable dans la
formation initiale et continue des
salariés futurs salariés des métiers de
l'aménagement paysager de l'horticulture
de l'environnement et de la forêt donc
concrètement pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le chef c'est ça sert à
ça le fait pas faire ces métiers ensuite
ça sert à acquérir des compétences ou la
découpe développe également ses
compétences en soit par l'intermédiaire
de formation initiale soit par
l'intermédiaire de deux formations
continues dans aujourd'hui des secteurs
en plaidant pour ces secteurs qui sont
porteurs aujourd'hui il ya en effet un
grand nombre d'offres à pourvoir dans
ces métiers et donc quelles sont les
formations vous délivrer sur place au
choc qu'on délivre différentes
formations on accueille déjà des jeunes
à partir de la 4e et la troisième
puisque on est donc agréé par le
ministère de l'agriculture
donc on a une spécificité se ressource
publique là et ensuite on offre des
formations diplômantes donc du ceap et
du bac professionnel a également du bts
1 aussi des certificat de spécialisation
mais les formations six adultes d'une
des formations courtes venir jeu pour
faire sa formation peut aussi se
reconvertir et faire des formations s en
échappe on peut se reconvertir comme
continuer à ce spécial comme ceux
spécialisés également donc à tout agent
nous on est en mesure de pouvoir
accompagner donc les personnes dans leur
projet professionnel
alors tout ça ça se passe au tremblay
sur mauldre sur un campus qui fait 21
hectares est ce que c'est idéal pour se
former à prendre dans ces secteurs de
métiers justement c'est idéal parce
qu'on a sur place tous les équipements
nécessaires pour
pouvoir mettre les jeunes ont de bonne
continuation pour des bonnes situations
pardon d'apprentissage on a également de
nombreux partenaires partenaires locaux
on travaille donc ce qui me permet de
faire ce qu'on appelle donc aussi des
chantiers écoles vont de pouvoir
travailler et les préparer faire des
séances pédagogiques dans des dans des
situations parce que quasi réel donc le
tout dans des conditions idéales comment
on intègre justement le chef très
simplement en venant nous rencontrer ce
qui est généralement donc on proposera
un premier entretien un échange donc
avec le responsable de la filière parce
que comme position sur trois filières
différentes de façon à pouvoir mieux
comprendre les attentes du jeune et pour
pouvoir justement lui apporter un
accompagnement le plus précis dans son
projet professionnel
on retrouve toutes les informations sur
le site du chef qui savent s'ils
s'affichent en bas de l'écran on
retrouvera notamment un reportage
prochainement sur cette filière un pour
les adultes 1 ces adultes qui viennent
au shape pour se reconvertir merci
stéphane amiot merci à vous deux
nouveaux directeurs du shape qui est
situé je rappelle à tremblay sur mauldre
quelques images à présent du 10e
triathlon de l'espérance avec un grand h
l'événement se déroulait dimanche
dernier au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin à montigny le bretonneux en
clôture de la semaine du handicap
rendez vous organisé par les bénévoles
de médias handicap avec l'objectif de
changer les regards trois défis en
situation de handicap était à relever
des défis goût les yeux bandés basket en
fauteuil et parcours fauteuil à embûches
était de la partie des comédiennes et
massenet et intervalles ding le
directeur de la rédaction de bfmtv est
thiery arnaud ou encore le mof et gérard
taurin montigny le bretonneux qui a
profité de l'événement pour remettre au
président de l'association média
handicap sébastien à un projet à la
médaille de la ville
le sport on part maintenant du côté du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 103e
édition de l'open de france a débuté
aujourd'hui sur les greens de l'albatros
le public a pu voir notamment les
golfeurs français victor dubuisson
alexander levy encore victor perez on
attend sur place près de vingt mille
personnes sur cette date automnale
inhabituelle pour cet événement
programmé est généralement pendant l'été
le directeur du golf national paul
hermitage au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de michael et demi d'euros
c'est différent parce que on est on est
pas du tout à notre date depuis 15 ans
dans l'habitude d'avoir le dernier
week-end de juin au premier week-end de
juillet et là on est mi octobre donc ça
nous change au niveau de la physionomie
un peu au niveau des vêtements par
exemple
mais mais franchement il ya de quoi
amusé et occuper le public qui vient et
c'est quasiment assuré un français
devrait terminer dans le top 10 après
cette première journée et ses pages en
main hébert qui enregistre pour le
moment un score de moins 5 pour
information est le dernier français à
s'être imposé lors de l'open de français
thomas levet et c'était en 2011 et
j'accueille à présent mélanie poquet
bonsoir votre rendez vous aux loisirs
vous allez faire parler notre âme
d'enfants de 7 à 77 ans ce week-end les
lego envahissent le perray-en-yvelines
des petites briques par milliers dans
les 600 m² de la salle de la main rôle
ou du perray-en-yvelines quarantaine
d'exposants va partager sa passion pour
ce jeu qui a rythmé l'enfance de
beaucoup d'entre nous c'est
l'association breezy qu'ils organisent
plusieurs diorama vont être présentés ça
représente en général un mois de travail
et cette exposition va vous faire
voyager à travers différents divers
univers où on décide de mettre en avant
une petite m
pour pour faire quelque chose d'un peu
plus grand que les autres
cette année on a décidé de mettre en
avant le train on a prévu un circuit à
peu près 25 mètres de long où on va
faire circuler des trains si possible
dans les autres dans l'est du ramadan
des exposants mais il y en aura aussi
pour tous les goûts mélanie certains
exposants vont s'inspirer des univers
fantastiques star wars ça ça me plait
harry potter et et aussi les super héros
et ils vont pas oublier bien sûr la
ville légaux sur ces deux jours
d'exposition il y aura aussi plein
d'animations le public pourra notamment
piloté des créations sur un bassin
nautique on pourra construire une
mosaïque on pourra même créé son propre
dieu rama
alors pour vivre 100% légaux rendez vous
samedi 19 et dimanche 20 octobre ou
perray en yvelines
le samedi c'est de 9h à 19h le dimanche
de 9 heures à 17 heures comptez 2 euros
pour les plus de 16 ans merci mélanie on
vous retrouve dans un instant votre
émission le 7-8 loisirs pour fuir le
tourin des idées de sorties à faire ce
week-end dans les yvelines
[Musique]
elle est à 30 ans la nouvelle miss
sirène france j'ai bien dit sirène la
plaisir oise julie peugeot est aussi une
passionnée de cosplay un loisir qui
consiste à imiter des personnages de
fiction tout en se déguisant le portrait
est signée michael et demi d'euros une
sirène dans les eaux yvelinoise la plaie
et oise julie peugeot 30 ans baigne dans
le maire meding depuis un an une
discipline insolite qui allie natation
et beauté avec un costume de femme
poisson en élasthanne cette discipline
requiert une préparation physique la
sportive plonge deux fois par semaine en
piscine
on nous demande des performances en
apnée en général je suis sur 40 secondes
une minute quinze ans vous avez
des figures à faire si vous souhaitez en
effet elles sont pas imposés mais en
effet il ya des vernis on doit aussi
également savoir poser sous l'eau on va
dire en mode très statique en complément
julie s'entraîne trois fois par semaine
sur terre dans une salle de sport
sécession lui ont permis de se présenter
au concours miss france de la discipline
une épreuve qu'elle a remporté en
juillet dernier en bretagne face à huit
candidates
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'étais allée ont plutôt en mode
plutôt défi personnel
je voulais vivre aussi une expérience
avec d'autres sirènes
parce que c'est pas tous les jours que
l'on peut rencontrer des sirènes en
france nous a permis de nous regrouper
de nous partager nos valeurs nos
connaissances nos savoir faire un titre
que la jeune sportive arbore fièrement
la piscine salvador allende des
clayes-sous-bois son lieu d'entraînement
depuis plusieurs mois ici tout le monde
est sous le charme de cette sirène d'un
mètre 65
je trouve que c'est une activité
un peu
un peu spécial mais très sympa un peu
magique
un peu comme ça donc dans un premier
temps on va l'accueillir et puis après
on va essayer de faire une activité avec
les gens qui puisse nager avec elle avec
de la musique en dehors des bassins
julie laisse de côté sa queue de sirène
pour s'adonner à son autre passion le
cosplay à loisir qui consiste à imiter
des personnages de fiction en se
déguisant après avoir créé son premier
costume en 2007 la plaisir oise est
aujourd'hui professionnel et réalise de
nombreuses séances photos pour montrer
ses créations à ses fans
tous les costumes que j'ai fait j'en ai
à peu près une vingtaine donc on va sur
plusieurs personnages on à la princesse
leia star wars à chenille de street
fighter pour ceux qui jouent aux anciens
jeux vidéo
j'ai sorti plusieurs costumes de lara
croft son dernier costume cassandra
l'héroïne d'un célèbre jeu vidéo
julie a passé plusieurs semaines l'hiver
dernier à le confectionner coût total
près de 2000 euros de matériaux vous
avez un matériau principalement mossi
ici layton qui est ici je voulais
qu'elle soit en permanence avec un
maintien de rapper comme comme dans le
jeu vidéo donc celle ci représente à peu
près oui 50 heures de travail
ces cinq jours à peu près prochain
objectif pour julie créer un costume
demi à une femme astek dans un jeu vidéo
la plaisir oise le présentera sur des
salons en 2020 cette information avant
de vous laisser ça a été confirmé cet
après-midi grève reconduite chez les
facteurs de versailles ils se mobilisent
depuis est lundi pour dénoncer notamment
un prochain plan de réorganisation de
leur service aussi une mauvaise ambiance
les facteurs de versailles 1 qui traite
notamment aux 6es les villes de buqueux
jouy en josas les loges en josas
notamment également vélizy voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci d'avoir suivi
demain vendredi place aux 7,8 l'hebdo
pour faire un retour complet sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
et quant à nous on se retrouve dès lundi
en direct à 18h pour une nouvelle
édition d'information locale belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]